Hallo und herzlich Willkommen zu UKW unserer kleinen Welt dem immer noch recht neuen Podcast Format von mir Tim Pritlove,
und ja heute steht sie dann an die zweite Ausgabe nachdem ich auf dem letzten Card complication Congress mit Reinhardt und Nicolas
mein Podcast Freundin einen lustigen Einstieg gemacht habe und noch vieles offen gelassen habe wohin denn hier die Reise so gehen könnte und das steht in dem Sinne auch noch nicht fest aber eine Sache die ich auf jeden Fall machen wollte ist auf
aktuelle Ereignisse,
einzugehen das kann gesellschaftliches sein das kann politisches sein oder vielleicht auch eine Mischung davon das lasse ich einfach mal ganz offen aber ein Thema was derzeit,
alle berührt mich persönlich auch sehr berührt aber darüber hinaus auch noch viele Leute total verwirrt ist der brexit.
Der geplante Austritt des Vereinigten Königreichs aus der Europäischen Union,
und wir alle mitbekommen haben dürfte geht's da sie mich will zu,
und um das mal ein wenig aufzudröseln und mal Einziehung zu schaffen was du da dich Phase ist,
habe ich mir den John eingeladen schon du hast hallo herzlich willkommen.
Hallo danke danke für die Einladung.
John du bist ja sie würde sich den selber beschreiben.
Also ich bin,
ein bisschen so bekannt dass ich dann Blog Zoe üblichen Themen schon seit über einem Jahrzehnt schreibe und dann wäre ich auch Europapolitiker und Verhandlungen an einige Universitäten
und ich bin ursprünglich aus Großbritannien wohne mittlerweile in Deutschland also ich habe selbst sehr viel von die EU profitiert an ich bin dann irgendwie,
genau deswegen dann so ein bisschen so an einem so brexit Experte irgendwie geworden kommt hier diese ganze Geschichte auf diverse Kanäle,
bisschen traurig natürlich diese Geschichte aber zumindest das vorge ich ja jeden Tag in Siena nicht nur weil ich persönlich betroffen bin weil aber weil ich finde es die ganze Ding sehe sehr interessant,
am unters das muss man das muss irgendein positiv begeistert Mensch auch dann faszinieren.
Ja mir ging es ja auch so dass ich dann angefangen habe mich sehr intensiv damit zu beschäftigen auch einfach umso den persönlichen Frust den man damit halt so ein bisschen zu verarbeiten.
Genau genau aber auch hinter einer Situation in meiner Situation Liebe hier in Deutschland zu sein und das ein bisschen so vom Fernseh beobachten aus da noch in Großbritannien seine sub mittendrin,
das macht das macht meine Freundin da ein bisschen so wahnsinnig wenn die das dann so jeden Tag erleben müssen hier haben wir zumindest in Berlin ein bisschen mit Esther.
Ja dann hat Domain deiner Webseite kann man schon ansehen du bist nicht gerade eine EU Skeptiker John warez.to das ist ja auch schon mal ein Statement.
Interstim ja auch ja also ich bin GoPro Hero EU aber ich will auf dem Kasten erform ich habe jahrelange auch für europäisches Föderalismus gekämpft also ich will das EU deutlich demokratische wird also ich
ja natürlich die EU ist Kobe eine gute Sache aber es ist man kann auch viel daran.
Und du engagierst dich ja auch konkret politisch.
Ja genau ich bin Mitglied der Grünen hier in in in Berlin ich war auch als ich noch in Großbritannien jahrelang Mitglied der Labour-Partei also ich habe auch dann so nicht mit so parteipolitische Themen zusammen mit EU Themen schon seit einigen Jahren dann er dann beschäftigt,
am
Aber so als EU uns gibt ischer Mensch hat man überhaupt viele Freunde installieren.
Ja das ist ein Grund auch dann ein bisschen so einen guten wo mich so sowohl hier in Deutschland fühle also meine Meinungen sind,
vielleicht nicht normal aber normale hier in dem Deutschland das erst in Großbritannien
ich hatte ja Glück als Kind ich habe Fremdsprachen gelernt ich war auf Schüleraustausch in Lahnstein bei Koblenz ich habe immer viel Zeit in Frankreich und Belgien verbracht also meine meine so Herkunft in Großbritannien ist
nicht so besonders Tipp ich muss ich muss ich auch mal immer sagen.
Ja gut aber ich meine so skeptisch das Land sein mag so international und global
ist es ja eilig im Kern auch also Großbritannien hat sich ja schon immer über die Welt ausgebreitet nicht unbedingt immer im guten London ist definitiv eine der Internationalisten Städte die man glaube ich überhaupt treffen kann auf diesem
Planeten.
Ja bald es gibt so grob 2 Großbritannien,
es gibt diese weltoffene Großbritannien London die Universitätsstädten hauptsächlich im Süden,
und dann gibt's diese nach innen blickende eher konservative Ex industrielle Großbritannien
und das ist was ich ihm hier in Deutschland in Decke so viele Deutschen haben zwei Seiten in London Oxford oder Cambridge verbracht habe ich war nie in Krasnodar,
oder Burnley oder Ebbe Weijl oder Sonnenbrillen und die sind dann die Arten von von Stetten die dann hauptsächlich für den Austritt gestimmt haben,
Städte die so wo wo ist wirtschaftlich nicht so gut geht wo Leute haben Angst vor der Zukunft,
an und dann ist es dann in dieses die diese so andere Großbritannien was was man so von fern nicht so beobachtet wo wo ist ist diese diese Spannungen.
Ist es nicht eher so dass es dieses andere Großbritannien England ist.
Ja ähm oder sage ich mal England und Wales also und Schottland und Nordirland sind beide ganz ganz anders politisch mittlerweile
aber wenn man schaut es gibt da keinen großen Unterschiede zwischen Süd walisische Industriestädte nur englische Industriestädte,
haben es kam zu diese brexit Frage also sagen wir dann mal England und Wales gegen Nordirland und Schottland.
Hat sich ja auch in der Abstimmung so auch gezeigt im Prinzip war ja die Mehrheit eigentlich eine englische Mehrheit und eine walisische.
Genau genau ohne uns und irgendwie Praxis USA ein Problem der englische Identität also am inwiefern hat.
England so seine Welt Rolle irgendwie verloren.
Und wie sieht die Zukunft von England dann aus es ist auch der Fall dass,
besonders Schottland nur die Wand zum Teil weil zum Teil haben dann irgendwie so ein eine eigene Identität gewonnen in den letzten,
zwei Jahrzehnten nach den Etablierung der denn den Geschossen Parlamenten walisischen assemblieren Ende der 90er,
aber England Roller innerhalb von Großbritannien bleibt nicht so unbeantwortet
also es ist auch da einer ein Aspekt sonnigen britische suspect England gegen die anderen Teilen Großbritanniens obwohl es ist über 40 Millionen von den sechs Millionen Einwohner Großbritanniens insgesamt wohnen in England so England ist in,
wichtigsten größtes gegossen.
Es gibt diesen Begriff des American exceptionalism als British accent schon wissen scheint mir das nicht ganz so ein definierter Begriff zu sein aber man,
meine Wahrnehmung ist dass es in Großbritannien und vor allem eben in England schon so eine,
Selbstsicht gibt das man irgendwie anders,
ist oder einen anderen Anspruch hat und auch das ganze Verhalten Großbritannien gegenüber der EU in den letzten Jahrzehnten hat das ja irgendwie immer mit transportiert.
Ja ja so ein Teil also Großbritannien hat nicht so wirklich akzeptiert dass Großbritannien so keine Weltmacht mehr ist kann nicht so nur alleine,
ohne europäischen Allianzen sososo da auf einer so eine Weltbühne dann dann dann stehen.
Ohne Sauter Fall dass Großbritannien oder die Bridge über Wirkung hat nie so,
den richtigen Gründen verstanden warum überhaupt,
die Großbritannien die EU damals in den 70er noch bei also für Leute in Deutschland die EU war immer ein Friedensprojekt.
In Großbritannien was war damals die Begründung betanin war wirtschaftlich LG sprach damals aber es gab und es gibt noch keinen guten Grund warum ist Großbritannien überhaupt ein EU Mitglied,
und diese Frage ist dann sehr sehr wichtig weil wenn die die Briten haben keine gute Begründung es ist dann schwierig,
die EU-Mitgliedschaft Bein so ein Volksabstimmung in 20-6 hinzu sowieso rechtfertigen also Großbritannien
Kämpfer oder England ist die interne Camp wie sieht die Zukunft des Landes aus wie sehen die die die internationale Beziehung Großbritanniens dann aus,
das ist das ist ein eingang ein Element vom von diese probro diese Problem mit mir die EU mit Brei,
es gibt auch natürlich anderen Problemen und anderen Hindernissen besonders im britischen politischen Kultur.
Weil diese sehr strittige Kultur auswischen labour labour gegen die Tories diese so zwei Seiten die die Briten haben die so verstanden dass,
in der EU alle können gewinnen,
ja also die Geburtenrate ist in Großbritannien gewinnen die EU verliert oder wenn die EU Gewinn Großbritannien verliert ist nicht möglich dass beide Seiten gleichzeitig gibt so gewinnen können,
bedenkt das deutsche Politiker und französische Politiker haben haben sich immer,
damit haben das immer besser verstanden wie man findet dann weg die die nationale Interesse und die EU Interesse so zusammenzuführen das haben die Briten dies durch.
Aber warum haben sie es nicht verstanden immer du hast gesagt es gab nicht so richtig ein Grund warum
Großbritannien in der EU sein muss jetzt kann man ja sagen ok da damals in den 70er Jahren waren die wirtschaftlichen Aussichten nicht besonders rosig
und seitdem ist es ja nur in den Vereinigten Königreich so schlecht gar nicht ergangen.
Ja das stimmt aber das Ding ist dann die haben das dann.
Wenn wenn man hört so die Parolen von denen von Knight Rider so you can even Espana es ging Großbritannien damals ready schleichen in die Siebziger dann kam faj in der achtziger sie hat dann alles gerettet und seitdem
ist die EU so eine Bremse auf die britische Wirtschaft nicht deine.
Also wir hätten da noch viel toller sein.
Ja ja genau genau ohne diese dieser Last der EU die ganze progressieren zweite wäre es dann so ein Wirtschafts Paradies für uns in Großbritannien gegen die war es Dacia mit dieser Wirtschaftsliberalismus hat hat
hat alles für große tanina Messgerät also das stimmt ja nicht aber das ist nur ein Teil der Debatte grob also das,
dass die Briten haben nie so richtig verstanden inwiefern die EU hat hat Großbritannien auch wirtschaftlich viel geholfen und und hilft Großbritannien noch,
also das ist dann auch dann ein ein ein Kern ein Kernproblem ist auch der Fall dass dieses so alltägliches Austausch zwischen.
Heinzelmännchen Feder Ochsental in Großbritannien viele Brötchen Bundesliga haben Zeit in den Vereinigten Staaten verbracht aber fast keine sprechen anderen europäischen Sprachen bestehen andere europäische Pilzkulturen,
vieler Deutschen haben in Großbritannien studiert obertauer haben gegen irgendwelche Kontakte da aber die Anzahl Embryonen gewonnen die deutsche du französisch sprechen ist sehr sehr gering also das bedeutet es gibt dann,
kein Verständnis von anderen politischen Systemen in Europa,
schöne mich an einen Paneldiskussion in der King's College London vor 1 Jahr gerade ich saß auf dem Panel mit dem,
ein Update der konservative Abgeordnete aus Gloucester und der sagt ist mir Johnny U-Haft understand,
russisch democracy ist einfach high quality ich will Weston View Franzosen gelacht also wie kann man auf,
sagen wir aber der Typ verscharrt eigentlich hat kein Verständnis davon wie anderen europäischen System überhaupt funktionieren
also das geht dann dann dann Seetiefe der hat da hat der Typ hat sie aber nicht blöd aber hat sich nie mit anderen der Mekka Schienensystem in in in Europe Geschäft.
Aber isst man das mit der Sprache das sehe ich natürlich auch aber es gibt doch auch Irland also ich meine Irland spricht ja nun auch englisch ist ja auch jetzt soweit nicht weg und kulturell vielleicht auch noch das Land was
Großbritannien am nächsten steht und in gewisser Hinsicht wenn wir eh noch drauf kommen mit Nordirland ja auch sehr eng verwoben ist,
Roland ist ja auch schon eine Antithese zu dem.
Ja das stimmt aber irisches Politik ist ganz anders als britisches Politiker so die anderen ganz anderes Wahlsystem die wie die Parteien funktionieren ist auch ganz anderes es ist auch dass das.
Ja aber das meinte ich ja auch es ist ist halt anders aber man kann ja zu hören.
Aber es ging nicht nur um schwach natürlicher obwohl er da der indische Premierminister war der spricht gutes Deutsch war sodass ich schon interessant Anime arbeiten ist er ist Irland hat auch die EU gesehen also,
auf.
Hatte das was Hilfe gegenüber den Arten find Großbritannien irgendwie also Elans poi europäische Haltung ist auch.
Zum Teil eine Reaktion so gegen Großbritannien ja ja.
Verpackt man derzeit aber auch ganz deutlich dass das auch jetzt greift und Irland hat ja auch sehr.
Genau die Landwirtschaft ich profitierte hat auch kulturelle irgendwie profitiert aus Irland ist deutlich offener geworden in den letzten Jahrzehnten,
dank die EU an.
Ist auch der Fall dass ich muss sagen dass die irische Politiker haben ein hervorragendes diplomatisches Arbeit gemacht innerhalb der EU in den letzten
34 Jahren die Kontakte zwischen Dublin und Berlin und Dublin in Paris sind so so viel besser als die Kontakten zwischen London Periode Paris and London und Berlin
die haben das sehr sehr gut und sehr sehr klug gespielt die die die ihren in denen in den letzten paar Jahren um sich so gegen diese dieser dieses der Folgen des brexits dazu.
Erstmals auf fällig ist grad die kleinen Staaten in der EU oder überhaupt in Europa,
ganz andere Internationalität pflegen weil sie einfach verstehen dass sie eigentlich alleine gar nichts mehr bewirken können und das scheint mir so ein Gedanke zu sein der in Großbritannien überhaupt nicht zu.
Das denn ich stimm dir da vorkommt.
Am bevor wir zu sehr in die aktuellen Sachen rein gehen ich würde gerne noch mal so ein bisschen mehr.
Hinterfragen inwiefern jetzt auch die englische und britische Geschichte auch dazu beiträgt dass.
Dass das Gedanken System so ist wie es gerade ist eine These ist ja also man hat das Empire den Verlust des Empires nie verwunden das wird auch sehr kontrovers diskutiert ob das eine eingängige Ansatz ist aber das,
wird schon eine Rolle oder.
Das spiel die irgendwie eine Rolle also wenn man Sonne sondern schaut in den Meinungsumfragen die die Briten haben ein besonders großes Problem mit einem gemeinsamen EU außen und Sicherheitspolitik weil die haben immer noch diese diese Meinung dass das Großbritannien doch noch ein Welt.
Handy in Großbritannien wir Briten das Kinder wir lernen fast gar nicht über die die britische kolonial Seiten,
das bedeutet es herrschen dann viele Missverständnisse innerhalb die politische Debatte also was hat Großbritannien getan warum funktionierte dann diese diese Kohle dieser zu Empire dann doch am Ende nicht,
das bestehende versteht die britische Bewölkung nicht so ganz.
Keine Politiker haben eine Interesse die Bridge über Wirkungen sein OK moment mal dieses diese euch guten oder schlechten Zeiten hängt von den Standpunkt aber aber diese sein sind.
Deutlich sind jetzt vorbei es diese diese Kolonie aus Einkommen nicht zurück jetzt Großbritannien muss.
Eine neue Welt oder europäische Rolle für sich finden also einer von der Debatte findet nicht statt also diese eine gewisse.
Angst vor der Rolle Großbritanniens gibt es ja schon aber umgekehrt auf der anderen Seite.
Keine Angst von wem jetzt vorbei.
Nur eine Angst vor der Zukunft irgendwie das man wusste irgendwie Viva Großbritanniens Rolle man weiß ja nicht so mehr wie das dann aussieht.
Manche haben dann Angst aus so Momenten guten großes Handy gehst du alleine nach dem brexit.
Das könnte Großbritannien schlecht gehen und man schauen deine okay dann die dann die die guten alten Zeiten kommen zurück also der der der der der Handelsminister Volkstheaters aus.
EMPIRE 2.0 beschriebenen eine Rede irgendwann mal also ja die Reaktionen zu dieses Buch war nicht so besonders positiv.
Aber was das bedeutet oder welche Alliierten hat Großbritannien,
wo sind die Großbritanniens engen Freundschaften,
das ist höchstens stecken also alle in die britischen Medien jajajajajaja K,
Kanada Australien und Neuseeland und so wenn Großbritannien unterstützen und man stellte dann Fragen an den
australischer Minister und der sagt nur so ist es für uns wichtiger ein Freihandelsabkommen mit der EU nicht mit Großbritannien also das stößt dann klar gegen so die dir so nationale Selbstbild der Briten also es kann sein dass das ist,
gar nicht einfach.
Ja direkt die Rettung des eigenen Landes auf der anderen Seite des Planeten.
Ja genau also man kann nicht soviel nachher nach Neuseeland exportieren aber dann irgendwie ist es dann schwierig für für für Großbritannien,
eine realistische neue Rolle für sich dann so finden aber man muss auch sagen auf der anderen Seite,
EU selbst war nie für Briten serbisch.
Wenn man schaut in den Meinungsumfragen in Großbritannien einmal im Jahr eine Meinungsumfrage dieses Jahr was sind die Top 20 politischen Themen für Sie jetzt.
Und zwischen den 70er Jahren um 20:15 Uhr erschien kein einziges Mal unter den Top 20 die EU.
Also die Briten Warenprobe EU skeptisch,
habe ich warte für die britische Bewerbung überhaupt nicht wichtig es war keine wichtige Frage also.
Wirtschaftlichen Fragen Außenpolitik Sozialpolitik Gesundheitspolitik die Schienen immer in die er unter den ersten 20,
Biopolitik oder Beziehung mit Europa kein einziges Mal bis 20:15 Uhr
also was bedeutet das diese Idee was man dann von konservative Politik blöd gehört gar so höchst umstritten dass man musste unbedingt ein Volksabstimmungen wegen Droge aus der Gesellschaft nein es gab kein Druck,
das war nicht Spannung in der hatte konservative Partei und das ist dann den guten vermisst du dieses diese beide dran gekommen ist also ja klar ich gebe diese so Exception müssen in Großbritannien,
und eine gewisse Euro Skeptizismus aber es gab nie von der Bewölkung herein richtig Druck auf dem polnischen System eine eine Antwort irgendwie auf diese Frage so zu finden.
Es kann man sich natürlich fragen was ist das jetzt sozusagen die Politik hat das Thema nicht aufgegriffen weil es der Bevölkerung nicht wichtig war oder die Bevölkerung hat es nie als wichtig angesehen weil die Politik ist auch nicht entsprechen.
Messing ist war die Rolle der konservative Partei ist hier in Scheiben.
Die konservative Partei in der 70er Jahren war poem und bis in der 80er Jahre.
Habe dann.
Und Leber waren die EU.
Lebe waren damals die EU Skeptiker die Position der Parteien haben sich so so gekreuzt dann so Ende der 80er die konnte mit ihm sind internet.eu skeptischer heute schon gegangen labour mehr pro-eu.
Und der startete und des Dacias Ausstatter diese berühmte Rede in Brügge gehalten wo sie sich dann Mitte der 80er sie gegen,
ein politisches Europa geäußert hatte die EU kann ein Wirtschaftsprojekt sein aber wir wollen wir wollen nichts Politisches hier.
Also das war dann den begin von dieser Spaltung innerhalb der konservativen Partei.
Die diese eu-ru skeptische Konzept sehr so rechtskonservative nationalistische Flügel der der der konservative Partei,
weg.de dann seit seid zu Ende der 80er,
Vätternsee besteht zwischen 92-97 als John Major Partei war Premierminister war weil diese sogenannten Maastricht Rebels machten da damals das Leben sie sich schwierig Würfel für John Major.
Und dann auf Tony Blair dann gewann,
an97 die konservative Partei rückte dann deutlich mehr nach rechts also die Leute die ich konnte die konservative Partei zu getreten sind zwischen 97 und 2005,
sind deutlich weiter nach rechts als die ältere Generation.
Diese Menschen sind dann die Menschen die dann an der Macht gekommen sind beide in innerhalb der konservativen Partei aus Kamerun dann Parteivorsitzende geworden ist in 2006,
also man hat die so so Echo Effekt das aus die Partei in der so einer tief.
So Anfang der 90er bis 2005 war die Leute die die die die konservativen Parteien zu getreten sind werden diese Periode sind dann jetzt die Leute die heutzutage an der Macht sind,
die Partei schon gespalten war wegen Bombe wegen Spannung mit der EU,
und die sind jetzt die Leute die die die drängen dann die konservative Partei in eine deutlich konservativer riecht.
Man muss auch nicht vergessen dass die konservative Partei ist mittlerweile sehe kein und Sierra,
es hat und 100000 Mitglieder also den deutschen CDU hat er über 400.000 also um die CDU ist kein Beispiel von einer lebendigen Partei,
und bei ein Durchschnittsalter von über 60 Jahre alt was bedeutet konservativ sind keine richtige Volkspartei mehr das ist eine sehr alten weißen auf dem Land lebenden Partei für Reiche alte Menschen.
Und an die die diese Menschen erinnern sich dann noch an Colonia sein in die von diese Seiten dann zurück
also das bedeutet dass man kein brexit mehr als Problem innerhalb der konservativen Partei sehen als Probleme ancienne hat Großbritannien insgesamt und das ist dann das sind dann die Wurzeln Vivi Designer fanden dann zustande.
Bevor wir vielleicht darauf eingehen will ich das gerne noch mal dieses diese Parteien Landschaft einwenig betrachten also Tories und labour
grob vergleichbar vielleicht mit dem.
Christlich-demokratischen Union Blog also mit CSU grob vergleichbar mit der SPD eins-zu-eins kann man das nicht machen aber eben auch hier war es ja lange Zeit so dass diese beiden Parteien im Wesentlichen so die Volkspartei
envato was ich ja im Wahlsystem in Großbritannien auch sehr viel mehr konzentriert als in Deutschland aber im Prinzip war die Kräfte ja ähnlich verteilt.
Wie sehr hat denn Leber jetzt sozusagen seine seine Wurzeln noch in ihrem Gründungsmythos und inwiefern ist das unter die Räder.
Bist du wirklich weit in die Tiefe Bein in diese beiden großen Parteien sind in Großbritannien nur so wichtig heute,
wegen den Brötchen var System also das hält diese Parteien zusammen also innehaben bekommt er mit jedem hat man alles vom Teil der AFD CDU und Teile der FDP
sagen wir grob machen und in der Labour-Partei alles was du so von den von Sarah Wagenknecht Bistro Berta
also die sind sehr sehr breiten Formate irgendwie oder Bündnissen.
Das ist weil wenn man Grunde seine neue Partei man hat wegen dem Boden mehrheitswahlsystem Großbritannien keine Chance oder keine richtige Chance ins ins ins Parlament rein Zug.
O2 System ist ja grob so als würde man in Deutschland die Zweitstimme abschaffen und dass man sozusagen nur die Wahl in.
Es ist nur in die 650 Wahlkreise ein Beispiel dafür außerdem die Brötchen EU skeptischen Pattaya hier keine penisparty die haben 13% der Stimmen in 20:15 Uhr die Küche aber dafür 1 von 650 sitzen im Mond heraus also das ist keine Demokratie,
und wenn es gibt diversen Darmpolypen Spannung nicht nur links rechts sondern Welt offen oder geschlossen poi europäische oder Euro skeptisch oder diversen Tendenzen in der Hafer und von vorne einen polnischen System,
die sind dann in den britischen Unterhaus dann gar nicht so gespiegelt sind dann sehr schwierig gerade für die beiden Parteien,
und besonders Anfälle was heißt labour hatte dann eine riesige Mitgliederzuwachs 20:15 Uhr an Corinna sich für den Parteivorsitz kandidiert.
Die neuen Parteimitgliedern sind hauptsächlich junge Menschen,
din Universitätsstädten wurden also dann labour hat das wird das allererste Mal mit der Parteigeschichte in Kensington also eins von den Bereichen start Hanlon und Incanto Bremen superreich und Weste Stadt in Kent gewonnen,
aber dann nur sehr knapp gewonnen in ehemaliger hochburger also Industriestadt in den Norden Englands wil Wheaton z.b.
Also labour verliert ein bisschen an dieser
so wie wir in den auf Englisch blue collar worker ist also wo er ehemalige Industrie arbeite und gewinnt dann an jüngere Wählergruppen die hauptsächlich Universitätsdiplom aha.
Also dann labour verliert diese so Tradition Isotretinoin würzen auch ein bisschen verloren,
und dann die Konservativen auch weil die Konservativen gewannen immer in diese in die sollen die Mittelschicht aus und die unter unternehme Ärzte Leute mit diversen professionellen Qualifikation also.
Aber Leute die dann relativ waren aber doch ein bisschen weltoffen aber aber die Konservativen gehen in so einer Sonne sehr nach innen Blick in die Richtung gerade,
und das war dann auch dazu ein Problem ist die beiden Parteivorsitzenden may für die Konservativen Kopien für die Labour-Partei,
may ist deutlich weiter nach rechts komin deutlich weiter links,
es gibt an dieser riesigen Ludger Männer haben das so der Mitte des politischen Systems gerade also dann lass bitte.
Ganze britischen polig Einparteiensystem ist gerade im Umbruch oder könnte im Umbruch sein.
Oder müsste eigentlich im Umbruch St.
Ja das Ding ist natürlich bei wenn dann ein noch erneut ein Bein eine Unterhauswahlen stattfindet wie Punkten dann diese diversen Parteien also und dann auf in meinen Blick in den Parteien hinein
Kim Sophie le querce und Flügel in der hatte von dem Papa nicht genießen sondern European research coperto dass du etwa 50 konservative Abgeordneten
zu den brexit Hardcore Arkos Autoleasing,
die sind super weit nach Reschensee CSIO euroskeptisch also wirklich so ASD mäßigen in die Position die die die die übernehmen aber die sind noch da
innerhalb von einer ehemalige Volkspartei
also und dann dann drücke ich dir Listen serayah Blick mal nach Deutschland borussia.de geht nein nein bleib mal hier bis zum parteiintern in Großbritannien die Positionen und nie die Hände der konservativen unterstützen sie sehr sehr so recht konservativ geworden
also das ganze politische System es gibt hier so hinter den Kulissen so viele Spannungen aber das.
Dass die Bahn im Haus sehen haben sechs normale noch Wandern hatten diese diese zwei großen Parteien noch aber hinter den Kulissen viele Tendenzen und verändern sich schon um und viel Bewegung.
Aber es gibt ja auch noch andere Parteien auch wenn sie schlechte Karten haben also,
das Wahlsystem des treibt ja wirklich lustige Züge als Captiva Aldi optiwisch bezogen hast die war das was man das 20.15.
Ja so vor dem Rhein von dem her.
Das war ja wirklich absurd ne also nicht nur Interview Cap mit 13% der Stimmen auf einen Sitz kam sondern die Scottish National Party hat in Schottland mit ich glaube 5% der Stimme also jetzt aufs ganze Land gerechnet 35.
Ja
53 ne.
Alle bis auf drei Akkorden in Schottland haben die gewonnen.
Genau das.
Das hatte ich schon bisschen absurd aber tragen denn diese anderen Parteien trotzdem nennenswert zum politischen Diskurs bei also.
Die ist gerade Schnellschnitt Party fällt mir in letzter Zeit also
man würde ja vom Namen her vermuten dass es jetzt sozusagen die AFD Schottlands das ist ja aber nicht sonst eine sehr sozialdemokratischer Links
geprägte Partei die ja auch da nicht glaube ich groß geworden ist dass sie halt für dieses Unabhängigkeitsreferendum Schottlands geworden hat das hat ja dann klappt nicht funktioniert der damalige Vorsitzende wie hieß er noch gleich.
Alexander Amend.
Damit genau ist zurückgetreten und hat dann den Weg frei gemacht für die neue Vorsitzende.
Niklas virgin die ich persönlich bemerkenswert finde.
Superfish sie ist die FaceTime Politikerin des Landes gerade also alles Ding ist die diese Schottland Frage wird erst.
In ein paar Jahren richtig krasser zurückkommen in Großbritannien weil es gibt ein es gibt diversen Problemen,
Hurricane fur die schottischen ganzen Listen gerade.
Das ist das viele Leute haben für diese Partei haben diese Partei gewählt obwohl die Gegner einen unabhängigen Schottland waren weil die waren ehemalige soziale Meccano der ehemalige labour Leber wähle die haben dann wegen den,
wirtschaftlich Wirtschaftspolitik von den SMP sind zu den SMP gewechselt.
Aber die spielen eine hervorragende Rolle im Mund Haus gerade die SMP also dies die haben viele sehr sehr kluge Abgeordneten die müssen die mischen sich in die alltäglichen Debatten ein
die bilden sogar in manchen Fällen eine bessere Opposition Suzuki Spacer brexit Politik
Eisleber sogar also die haben die haben echt kluge Menschen mit lustigen ist sehr sehr fähig bleibt immer sehr ruhig,
Azad alle immer immer die richtigen Dingens und zum Thema brexit für Schottland aber auch für alle in Großbritannien die die die die den Verbleib unterstützen aber.
Ich denke dass diese Unabhängigkeit Frage wird erst,
so Ende dieses Jahrzehnt nee nee dann dass ich schon nächstes Jahr dann dann in ein paar Jahren dann zurückkommen dass so ein brexit brexit muss zuerst irgendwie gelöscht werden und dann kommt wieder diese diese Frage der Tod wieder Unabhängigkeit dann mal.
Was ist dann gibt es noch die Liberaldemokraten.
Ja die stinken sehen dann so einer in einer in eine Krise ist ein bisschen zu.
Hast du harte Worte aber die sind zurzeit ein bisschen irrelevant also die waren in diese Koalition mit den konservativen bis 2015 und die haben dann,
eine Serie von Niederlagen gehabt seitdem der Tag der Parteivorsitzende.
Der ist des alt und es fehlt ihm Ideen die Partei sieht auch so aus.
Nicht lebendig und Joana und unter die Partei die Partei hat profitiert nicht so wirklich von denen.
Probleme in den Haaren von den anderen Parteien nicht Sony.
Obwohl sie auch nicht von Anfang an immer pro-eu waren und gegen den brexit.
Genau ja aber die die haben so an glaubwürdigkeiten und an Unterstützung verloren zwischen 20:10 Uhr und 20:15 Uhr.
Zu Recht oder nur weil sie bei den Tories unter die Räder gekommen sind.
Es war nicht wegen Theo Positionen es war wegen Bildungspolitik hauptsächlich unter dem vorherigen Parteivorsitzende Kleid.
Ich denke aus meiner Sicht jetzt ist ein bisschen Unrecht man muss man sein OK in einer Koalitionsregierung muss man.
Muss man Kompromisse machen ich finde es irgendwie ein bisschen traurig aber die die die Liberalen sind sind wir jetzt gerade keine Lösung für diese ganze Brett.
Oder gibt's noch grüne.
Ja
Prozent der Stimmen bekommen haben aber auch.
Ja auch nur einen Sitz im Unterhaus dann breit mit mit Colorline newcos also.
Gewinnen Andi gewinnen an Unterstützung kann ein Lukas die Didi bekannt die dieser diese einzige grüne Abgeordnete ich sehe fähig taucht sie regelmäßig in den Medien auf.
Aber viele so sage ich so weltoffene linken die.
Theoretisch Grünen wählen könnten sind nicht bereit zu was machen weil die wähle noch labour's ist genau meine la meine Situation also richten in Deutschland wähle ich grün.
Aber in Großbritannien schwele noch labour weil in den Wahlkreis wo ich noch meinen Stimmrecht habe in Großbritannien,
die beiden Parteien die Kvarner klar vorne sind sind die Tories und labour und ich muss Leber wählen weil ich will auf keinen Fall dass ein Tor da gewinnt,
also in in großen Handelswaren ist viele linken mussten so eine Entscheidung treffen und das bringt natürlich inwiefern die die Grünen relevant sein können aber anderen Ebenen,
Lohner Regierung auf die lokale Ebene Tag ist die grüne bisschen besser aber auf die nationale Ebene wegen den var System es ist immernoch Zebra.
Mach mal den Reigen voll was auf der übersehen wird ist das Vereinigte Königreich vereinigt der nicht nur die drei Königreiche Großbritanniens also der rechten Insel Sonne
dann eben auch der anderen Insel Irland und dort gibt es Nordirland.
Was ja sozusagen das Überbleibsel der englischen Besatzung der Insel geblieben ist.
Und halt jetzt immer noch dazu gehört das Parteiensystem dort ist auch sehr.
Ja und ist ganz anders also an es ist auf religiöse Unterschiede also gesparten.
Besonders sehr wichtig die die diese diese so rechtskonservative protestantische Partei die Democratic unionist Party
Patrice amaze Regierung in London ist von die Unterstützung von diesem DUP Abgeordneten abhängig.
Die waren für für den brexit.
Weil die mochten nie so gerne dieses Zusammenarbeit mit den irischen Republik.
Und die waren immer traditionell Alliierten von den Konservativen in den in London.
Das ist trotz dieser Situation dass eine Mehrheit der Note irische Bürger für den Verbleib in der EU bei dem bei der Volksabstimmung sich geäußert hat und auch.
Die die Karten die Partei mit katholische Unterstützung ist Shin Fane,
die nehmen deren sitze im britischen Unterhaus nicht obwohl die Recht auf 7 Sitze da haben war die sind dann für ein vereinigtes Irland und dafür kämpfen die.
Warum nehmen Sie diese Plätze nicht an.
Also ziehst durchgesehen dass die wollen in die sehen das aus Wasserart Kollaboration mit mit dieser gehasste macht in den Ninja in London,
also es wäre sehr lustig wenn dich wenn ich in Venne die diese diese dann sieben Sitze dann dann dann dann nimmt weil dann von ein paar bisschen nächsten verliert dann sowieso mehr er das
zitterst ja sonst immer hat.
Könnten sie denn das tun.
Ja die Jurist dich ja schon aber die Partei hat sie schon dazu geäußert sage nein das tun wir nicht,
ja weil dass ich gegen so einer Kernpunkt der da der der zum Park der Partei keine Kollaboration mit blonden also ja.
Auch wir auch wenn sie damit jetzt sozusagen eigentlich alle retten können.
Jaja ist ein bisschen ein Widerspruch aber gut ja ja ja ja man die die irische.
Haarteil anschaut nordirische Partei Landschaften aus dem brexit Landschaft ist sehr sehr interessant weil Belfast hat mir heilig für den Verbleib gestimmt.
Lieben Brief in time Nordirland wenn man schaut aus somit Karte hat für den Austritt gestimmt,
außer dieses Hotel an der Grenze also man hat so drei Ringen,
Belfast für den Verbleib alles drumherum für den aus und alles dann an der Grenze zu den irischen Republik dann wieder für den Verbleib,
über die Diane ganze wohnen die verstehen worum es geht weil die Genien Tage über die Grenze es gibt bauhöfer mit Fell auf eine Seite und auf der anderen Seite riesen der viele Exporte Leute und Leute die auf eine Seite leben und auf der anderen Seite Arbeit.
Also was bedeutet das ist dann worum es dann,
es ist so besonders schwierig ja die diesen runden die ist nur dieser Situation nicht nur wegen dem Partei Landschaft sondern die wird wegen die wirtschaftliche Kontakte und wegen dieses dieses Problem dass das trizemeister Regierung ist von den,
endlich Schluss mit der TUP dann abhängig also ja das ist warum ist das so eine zentrale Frage ist für für die für diese brexit-verhandlungen.
Die OP war ja so traditionell eigentlich gar nicht jetzt die primäre Vertretung der Unionisten sonst klappt ja noch diese Alster unionist Party.
Ja die waren weniger weniger radikal also die die etwas radikalere Unionisten haben dann seid so über ein Jahrzehnt dann an an Bedeutung gewonnen ja also das macht das dann noch schwieriger.
Die haben.
Idope die Queen an umzustürzen weil die die sind so echten Nationalisten oder oder oder kämpfen für die Interessen von Nordirland und die und die.
Priorität Nummer eins ist Nordirland bleibt ein Teil von Großbritannien also das ist der allerhöchste Priorität die sagen wir wollen keine Unterschiede zwischen wie alles in mini nur die Airline geregelt wird,
und wie alles im Rest von Großbritannien also eine Lösung wäre.
Fand ich so eine Grenze in dem irischen See so machen statt zwischen Nordirland und in irischen Republik aber das liegen die die jupi vollkommen.
Ja sag mal vielleicht mal kurz noch mal diese Situation auch noch mal genauer beschreiben.
Mit Nordirland weil das ist ja eine hat sich zumindest als der Knackpunkt eigentlich in den brexit Verhandlungen schlechthin entwickelt alles andere war so naja könnte man so machen könnte man so machen könnte man so machen aber Situationen Nordirland ist halt die das
der über Jahrzehnte stattfindende Bürgerkrieg sage ich mal der lustigerweise und da zeigt sich immer so diese,
Zurückhaltung der Briten so schön dir da einfach als krabbelt bitte.
Jajajajajaja.
Ich gehe aber davon aus also Revolution ist Andi auch in England nicht möglich weil sie sich ging.
Die haben die bei dir nicht gehörte nicht ne.
Sich gegenseitig die ganze Zeit auf die Füße treten und müssen die ganze Zeit sorry sagen und würden überhaupt gar nicht so richtig zu kommen zu eine Revolution zu starten,
auf jeden Fall diese troubles war natürlich signifikantes gab über Jahrzehnte ich kenne das ja auch noch aus meiner Kindheit immer so Tagesschau angeschaltet hat
heute die Bombe hier morgen die Bombe da und dann wurde auch mal London was gesprengt oder zumindest geräumt das war einfach nur eine permanente
terroristische Realität
die mit dem Good Friday agreement also mit dem Friedensvertrag nach einem Referendum in Nordirland lustigerweise ein Referendum was mit.
Ja so sehe mit mir halt im Süden etwas weniger Norden habe aber schon eine gute Mehrheit auch in.
Ja auf jeden Fall ein Referendum mit einer sehr hohen demokratischen Legitimation auch weil im Gegensatz zu der Abstimmung über den brexit,
vorher ja auch genau klar war was für eine Regelung danach in Kraft tritt ja und das existiert und das gilt natürlich und ist ein internationaler Vertrag zwischen Irland und Großbritannien und darin steht,
das Mutterland und Irland im selben wirtschaftlichen also exakt selben wirtschaftlichen System existieren.
Ja ja ist nicht so ganz also das ja vergleichbar aber dass die.
Da drin steht dass die es muss keine Grenzkontrollen geben.
Und dann freier Personen und Warenverkehr ist dann über diese Grenze dann gesichert also diese Karfreitagsabkommen ist auf den Basis von so ein Kompromiss,
gemacht worden das für Leute aus den irischen Republik.
Die können agieren aus Irland war dann irgendwie vereint,
man könnte da arbeiten leben im Norden Wetter einkaufen gehen alles wie als wäre es ein Land.
Alle d-factor.
Du eine Insel,
auf der anderen Seite politisch war es noch getrennt also nur die Irland gehört noch zu Großbritannien hat seine eine eigene Regierung es ist die Souveränität nur die Irland ist noch von Großbritannien abhängig ist nicht von Dublin
also was war dann diese Art von Kompromiss also ein sein haben das akzeptiert die wollten keine kein Bürgerkrieg mehr also das wann denn dann.
So den grundsätzlichen Kompromiss hier in diese Karfreitagsabkommen das Problem ist dann um diese Grenze offen zu halten,
man braucht die gleichen Seilschaft nicht anders auf der A auf beiden sein also das war dann durchaus möglich weil Irland und Großbritannien waren in der EU man hatte schon gemeinsam Produktstandard eine eine gemeinsame so aus System
das macht dann also das macht er das ganze dann dann möglich also die EU ermöglichte dann dieses Karfreitagsabkommen los mir nicht die die wirtschaftliche teil,
das Problem ist dann wenn große kann ich vielleicht die EU.
Ich gebe dann anderen bei ich habe dich schneidest oder anderen Song hören auf eine Seite als auf der anderen Seite man muss dann Kontrollen dann an der notitia ganze dann einführen.
Oder Großbritannien findet dann ein brexit Lösung wo entweder nur die Irland oder ganz Großbritannien respektiert mehr von den europäischen regeln,
also sogenannten brexit also einen sanften brexit bedeutet dann keinen hart keine harte Grenze in nur Dilan also das ist eine Lösung Sanduhr brexit keine harte Grenze fertig.
Aber dann will man die Tories die wollen kein sandten brexit also die wollen einen harten brexit Yvonne Aigner
Handelsverträge mit anderen Ende der Welt unterschreiben können und die wollen eine ende der Personenfreizügigkeit also das akzeptiere die EU,
MVA mit einem seinem,
engen Wirtschaft in Verbindung mit mit Großbritannien dann nicht also was bedeutet das was für ein brexit Theresa May will,
passt nicht zu den Karfreitagsabkommen.
Also das ist dann wie diese sogenannten nordirischen bikestop dann zustande gekommen ist dieses Wachstums einfach man dazu sagen ok mittelfristig kann es keine harte Grenze geben.
Wir wissen nicht so genau wie wir das tun,
also könnte man irgendeine elektronische oder Tab technotex textbasierte Sol-System einführen,
damit man man weiß es gibt die weißen Sol-System in auf beiden Seiten der Grenze aber an der Grenze selbst keine Kontrollen,
na ist die Idee.
De Uhren die Irland glauben nicht so wirklich daran dass sowas je funktionieren kann und die haben so gesagt okay wir wissen auch wir auf Greifswald auf keinen Fall eine ganze hier geben,
wir hoffen dass technologische Lösungen Abi Fall diesen technologischen Lösungen dann nicht funktionieren dann.
Es muss eine engere Beziehung geben zwischen Nordirland und die Rest der EU aus zwischen Großbritannien und der Rest der EU und das ist dann die vorgeschlagene Lösung,
das Leben Dani konservative Abgeordnete nehmen in London ab und das Link allen auch die die jupi Abgeordneten ab von diesem wir wollen keinen anderen Standard sie notieren es im Rest von von England.
Das geht dann auch nicht und das ist dann dieses km diese Spannung ist und hat das dass man kann es dies ist Karfreitagsabkommen und diese offene ganze in Not Irland,
nicht dauernd respektieren wenn Großbritannien einen harten brexit will grob gesehen.
Mich entscheidet dann man dann mal ok eine Sonderlösung für Note Irland Link EDU piab eine Zollunion
zwischen großen ganz Großbritannien und die EU Lehne alle konservativen das ab also dann das ist dann dieses Pergament
von diese ganzen Probleme im britischen Unterhaus gerade ist dass es dann den Grund warum weil wenn man WLAN auf eine Grenze in Irland das bedeutet dass Großbritannien muss dann andere brexit Variante dann akzeptieren und das lehnen die Konservativen gerade.
Jeder lernt irgendwas ab und es gibt.
Ergebnis Karneval Neheim leinegarde jaja alle sind gegen alles und für nichts.
Vorhin hast du gesagt dass in Großbritannien wird die EU nicht mit Frieden gleichgesetzt,
ist ja eigentlich lustig weil das Karfreitagsabkommen ist im Wesentlichen durch die EU ermöglicht auch von der EU ausgehandelt worden und hat alle 30 Jahre Krieg beendet und das auch noch genau da also.
Ich finde das eine Schande muss ich.
Ich war um es mal mit 27 in Nordirland der also ich habe,
ich habe den 20-30 Einwohner europäische Länder habe ich schon getrunken sucht euch zum ersten Mal in Nordirland also ein bisschen verrückt das meinst du nicht.
Wann war das wann war das jetzt.
Minuten schon vor 14 Jahren einfach so zur Schau schon nach dem Karfreitagsabkommen aber als Kind ja ich bin 38 Jahre alt also nicht so alt.
Das Kind ich will mich daran dass ich nach longue Gange bin mit meine Familie ich habe schon meine Fahrzeuge so gefragt warum gibt's keine Mülltonnen auf den Straßen hier ja wegen Terrorismus gif.
Und mein Onkel lebt in manches das internationale rieseneier Ray Bombe so Mitte der neunziger also das hat das Leben der Menschen in England betroffen wäre der 90er.
Wieso ist es dann nicht wichtig für die Menschen den Großeltern das verstehe ich nicht also ich war nie in orisant.
Mein Leben hart betroffen und die Auswirkungen von von dieses Bürgerkriege Nordirland hat das Leben von alle Engländer betroffen,
wieso ist es dann möglich sei mir ok diese Note Ingenieur so wir spielen da ein bisschen wenn das bremst unser harten brexit Kurs ja also wir können uns nicht darum,
was ist so höchste ohne Verantwortung.
Und es geht dass dass es so fast keine Rolle gespielt hatte vor dem vor dem Referendum das finde ich unglaublich vielleicht ist das mit sie mit dem mit mit.
Nicht dass ich natürlich sehe ich die EU als Friedensprojekt aber dass ich.
Das in Deutschland gesehen habe wie diese Debatte um Frieden noch sehr wichtig ist in Deutschland.
Eine Debatte um Frieden ist überhaupt nicht wichtig in die sagst du die Englisch britische politische Debatte und inwiefern Großbritannien froh sein muss das ist kein Bürgerkrieg mehr gibt.
Das kommt bei den Menschen in England gar nicht an.
Und wenn man schaut in den Meinungsumfragen viele Briten seine viele Engländer sagen ja lieber no-deal angehen lassen ja wenn das bremst unsere brexit Kurs lass die dann gehen.
Ich finde es echt traurig aber wenn man Bauschaum den Wahnsinn bringen das ist was die Briten sagt.
Das ist ja auch dass ich dich eine Option weil diesen Karfreitagsabkommen steht ja auch drin dass wenn sich irgendwann mal die öffentliche Meinung in Nordirland ändert dass es dann auch ein Anrecht gibt auf ein neues Referendum wohl über die Zugehörigkeit der Republik Irland abgestimmt.
Ja ja das stimmt es gibt langsam steigende Unterstützung für sowas in in Nordirland aber zurzeit nicht ausreichend also das wenn nicht in den nächsten paar Jahren.
Ich habe gehört dass es seit diesen seit letzten seit einigen Monaten das erste Mal eine Mehrheit gibt dir den Umfragen.
Ja ja eine knappe Mehrheit aber das Ding ist man brauche dann eine politische Kampagne dafür und dass das kann ich zurzeit nicht vorstellen also mittelfristig vielleicht schon aber aber kurzfrist.
Ich hab so schön Fan Politiker sehr optimistisch gesehen aber das ist vielleicht auch hier.
Ja aber das ist auch.
Die Realität ist komplizierte denke ich aus als die beiden Seiten dass das vorstellen muss auch nicht vergessen dass das ID von einem vereinigtes Irland höher.
Leute der irischen Republik das klingt ja schön.
Haben uns auch nicht vergessen dass nur die Irland ein Drittel AMA pro Kopf ist als dies Republik also was wäre dann auch ein großes wirtschaftliches.
So ein bisschen wie die deutsche Wiedervereinigung ne.
Also ja es wird nicht kurzfristig kommen.
Etwas anderes ist mir noch aufgefallen wo glaube ich auch.
Aus einer kontinentalen Perspektive heraus was nicht so richtig gesehen wird ist dass die Medienlandschaft in Großbritannien auch extrem extrem ist,
wie muss man sich das so vorstellt es gibt noch keinen fox news Sauce gibt keinen Hardcore right-wing TV TV-Sender der jetzt die ganze Zeit.
Aber ich arbeite gegen Zeitungen die die Hardcore sind.
Berlin.
Deine Mail the sun besonders also ist ganz Zeitungslandschaft ist.
Also rechtspopulistisch Sunday Express deine Mail.
Auch die ehemaligen seriösen Zeitungen telegram von Toronto times sind er für den Austritt Unterstützung sehr so konservative Meinung.
Auf der linken Seite gibt's hauptsächlich dann nur Guardian und mit deinem RAF.
Abi haben deutlich weniger Leser aus als die die die die Zeitungen so auf den auf der rechten Seite,
und dann zutage so genau in der Mitte gibt's the BBC und jede die Rolle der BBC ist in in diesem diese ganze Geschichte auf serbisch.
Kann selbst Berichterstattungen auf der BBC Sontheimer brexit nicht mehr hören,
aus und das erschreckt mich weil ich bin sowas Kind in dem BBC so groß geworden das war immer so morgens und abends.
So ein medialer Mythos ne.
Egal also ist es ich will nicht sagen dass die.
Eine bestimmte Linie in diese brexit Geschichte unterstützen worden.
Aber es ist scheiße mit krampfhafte neutral.
Aber das Ding ist ja Wirtschaftswissenschaftler sagt no deal brexit ist eine tolle Sache,
Ernst Nathan unser anstehen 400er ist schaff ich nicht Schaffler die sagen ja das ist eine Kraft schlechte Sache aber das ist dann in der Berichterstattung 121.
Du bist wie oft Klimawandel.
Genau also ohne dich sehe interessant dass du das sagst.
Die haben so eine internes Prozess durchgeführt vor einige Jahren,
damit die beste über Klimawandel berichten können nach einem fairen atemweise nicht mehr Pro und Contra.
Und Pro und Contra mit brexit ist es dann sehr schwierig war in manchen Dingen gleichen sich nicht aus es gibt ein Positionen von verschachtelten dafür dass rauszugehen ist,
wirtschaftlich schädigen für Großbritannien das ist das ist eine ausgeglichene Debatte also.
Das bedeutet wir halt keine Ahnung wie viel das auf deutsch Übersetzer wir benannt das false equivalence,
Obama auf Englisch weiß nicht wie man das genau übersetzt und ich finde das,
the BBC sieht alles so aus der Westminster Perspektive also alles dreht sich um die Parlamentsdebatten im Unterhaus also die Berichterstattungen aus Brüssel,
von dipon.de wie die BBC Korrespondenten die die die die da arbeiten sind von einem miserablen Qualität also heraus meine sich die verstehen immer noch nicht,
wie
die EU-Institutionen funktionieren also ich ich finde dann gerade die die Qualität der Berichterstattung auf BBC Radio und im Fernsehen leider von einem sehr geringen Qualität.
Warum ist das so.
Das ist BBC steht unter sein besonders seit 2010 unter Überriesen Fehldruck.
Schön für die Konservativen es wär die Konservativen lieber wenn der BBC nicht existiert ja das ist so ein.
Öffentliches Fernsehen von einer Art Fernsehbeitrag finanziert in Großbritannien.
In so einem das passe nicht in den Weltbild der konservativen ja alles kann privatisiert werden.
Die haben sich nie zugetraut the BBC so privatisieren,
aber die haben deine binchy unter großen finanziellen Druck gesetzt ja finanziell kurzum eine Reduktion von den von der Zahl der Mitarbeiter.
So das war dann für die Filme BBC dann schwieriger.
Richtig gut sieht Berichten aus als es vorher war.
Die haben dann eine Entscheidung getroffen ok diese brexit-referendum ist dann vorbei wir berichten jetzt aus Horb.
Diese diese Situation ist nicht mehr umstritten ja so ist es da nichts gibt einen Konsens in Großbritannien gute Talente aus fertig,
da brechen wir dann so darüber also ist es wird eine lange Zeit brauchen bis viele sage ich mal,
politisch motivierte Menschen mal wieder der BBC vertrauen kann ich will nicht sagen es ist gefiel viel auftritt und so die die Leute sagen weiß BBC nee das ist nicht meine Position,
die Babys die Berichterstattung ist leider von einem schlechten Qualität es ist nicht,
auf so dass die BBC.
Will eine besondere Linie unterstützen nee das ist weil die haben nicht den Weg gefunden fair und korrekt über den Brötchen aus Flensburg.
Es gibt ja noch andere Fernsehsender die durchaus Einfluss haben ich fand die Berichterstattungen.
Kann FOS am allerbesten.
Dafür ausgeglichener.
Ja und manche Berichte auch auf sky Newton ab und zu der das kein Newsletter wirtschaftskorrespondent Faisal Islam der geht jetzt leider gerade der hat nach einer super gut an Weise über Bericht über brexit berichtet.
Es gibt einige anderen,
in manch anderen Zeitungen also ich folge dann Siena die Berichterstattung von einige Journalisten von diversen Zeitung suppito Forster von The Daily Telegraph der ist ganz ganz gut gibt viele gute Menschen die für die Financial Times schreiben,
Jennifer Rankin die Brüssel Korrespondent inform Guardian ist auch sehr klug.
Ian dunt ja also aber der ist sehr der ist mehr als so Kommentator ja so der Macht nicht so,
den berichtet nicht der der nimmt dann die die die Schlussfolgerungen von oder kann ich gute keinem was etwas bedeutet der ist nicht aller beste um,
genau herauszufinden was was geschah auf einem Gipfel oder oder oder oder hinter den Kulissen quellensee kriegen am Samsung Codes von der time z.b. der sehr gut im VIP wir berichtet was.
Was passierte in den britischen Unterhaus und Hinweise hinzu den Kulissen in den in den großen Tag ein bisschen so dieser.
So News Nachrichten und dann,
opinion in or Pets die so ein bisschen zu trennen also ein Bereich der so so.
Optimieren ist Dani ändern sehr gut aber dann anderen sind dann sehr gut in der so der alltägliche Berichterstatter.
Aber so in der Öffentlichkeit schlägt das alles nicht so richtig durch und hat so nicht den Eindruck dass wirklich auch in der aufgeklärte und ergebnisoffene Art und Weise über alles Bericht.
Da stimme ich vollkommen zu,
es ist dann sehr schwierig also weil dieses Thema ist ist sehr komplex die diversen Medienberichten nach diversen Arten Ferhan und weisen
am um dich die die tägliche Spielereien zu folgen da muss man eine Menge Zeit investieren um um das überhaupt zu verstehen.
Auch mal schicken,
Sprüche oder oder oder unterdrückt oder abends sind in der in der Bewölkung gar nicht so richtig verstanden also viele gehen davon aus dass no deal brexit Hans-Werner brexit ohne Einigung bedeutet dass der Situation wird gleich bleiben,
nein das ist blöd dass Großbritannien stürzte aus ja also wenn man schaut in den Meinungsumfragen inwiefern die Briten verstehen worum es geht also.
Nee also es geht es gibt große Missverständnisse noch,
und da da mal wieder so zu nehmen wie sie also die BBC hat eine deutlich größere Reichweite als alle anderen Medien aus und wenn die britische Bewölkung besteht nicht worum es geht.
Die Buddy BBC ja muss er nicht wisse verantworten darüber dafür übernehmen.
Das eigentliche,
brexit-votum selber ist ja jetzt sehr umstritten aus vielen Gründen nicht nur jetzt vom Ergebnis her sondern auch wie es zustande gekommen ist zunächst einmal,
das ist ja etwas Kurier weil es ja technisch betrachtet non-binding war also im Prinzip ist es eigentlich mehr eine Meinungsumfrage gewesen als dass es jetzt in irgendeiner Form irgendjemanden zu irgendetwas verpflichtet trotzdem
hat man so den Eindruck dass du bist die Tories
Theresa May das beste Beispiel das ganze jetzt sozusagen als die nächsten Auftrag aller Zeiten ansieht und überhaupt nicht auch nur einen Schritt davon,
abweichen kann andererseits war natürlich auch die Wahl unter einem erheblichen,
externen Einfluss kann man sagen der ganze Skandal um Cambridge analytica hatte er auch in Großbritannien Rolle gespielt ich glaube es sind mittlerweile alle Gruppen die für leaf.
Die haben Strafen gekriegt und muss einen Strafgelder bezahlen.
Genau also es war im Prinzip alles andere vielleicht nicht vollständig aber doch sehr umfangreich illegale Aktivität wie dort mit Geldern und Spenden umgegangen worden ist
Organza von abgesehen das ja nun auch wirklich die Webseite mit einer Argumentation an den Tag gegangen ist die nachweislich viele viele Lügen enthalten hat.
Das ist jetzt alles bekannt.
Bitte keine Rolle im öffentlichen Diskurs ich habe so das Gefühl das müsste doch an sich schon einmal alles sehr skandalös sein und irgendwie dazu führen dass die Leute vielleicht,
das Gefühl bekommen naja also wir haben ist 1,5 % Mehrheit erarbeitet
aber es wurde einfach nur mit Lügen und mit illegalen Methoden gearbeitet vielleicht.
Ja aber Ding ist.
Das alles dicht und es ist non-binding also.
Ja aber aber.
Warum also warum wird es so ernst warum wird es zu ernst genommen warum gibt es keine mentale Bewegung die sagt naja also so wie das jetzt gelaufen ist und so und klar wie auch die Formulierung war dazu Erinnerung.
Das passt in den britischen Selbstbild nicht also die Brücken sind ehrliche Menschen die haben ehrlich gestimmt die haben,
gut entschieden nicht gab gute Gründe mich persönlich nicht so gearbeitet das ist wie im tv wie das argumentiert wird gerade in in in Großbritannien,
und ja das war so nur so an der Grenze ein bisschen fragwürdig.
Soundso Muskat Diba niemanden hat der Regierung hatte jede Interesse Untersuchungen machen wegen.
Die parteiinterne Spannung in den hat der konservativen Partei also man muss nicht vergessen dass drei Viertel der konservativen Mitglieder sind für ein EU-Austritt,
das bedeutet dass ich überhaupt nicht populär ist wenn die Regierung sowas dann untersucht.
Also das ist dann eine mcweasel hat keinerlei Motivation das alles zu untersuchen.
In den Medien Guardian hat darüber viel berichtet aber die anderen Medien nicht so ganz.
Jan und sagen ja aber das war das größte demokratische Teilnahme Prozess der britische Parlamentarier Politikgeschichte das stimmt auch nicht der ist gehabt Wahlbeteiligung bei der Unterhauswahl 290 war war.
Aber das bedeutet dass die die die die die Party findet nicht so richtig statt,
irgendwie die,
die Briten haben nicht bestanden dass die haben ein demografisches Problem nicht nur mit dem Refrain sondern auf das war's System mit Buddy Unterhaus und die finanzieren in der Regel nicht nur für Referenden sondern für Unterhauswahlen.
Aber das passt nicht in dieses Selbstbild dieser Großbritannien ist seine historische Demokratie und die demokratischen Systemen funktionieren also.
Das geht einfach nicht im Bad aus wenn man versucht,
in einer so ein an diese Radioshow in Großbritannien diese diese Themen zu debattieren ich komme nehme dann das Antwort,
ja aber das war eine deutliche Mehrheit für den Austritt lass uns nicht mal wieder zu den Videos und zu dem Thema zu gehen oder.
Dass die die die Leute ja Willi the people Birdy
ja es war ein furchtbarer säuferin das respektiert die die die ganze regelmäßig gab keinen Plan für den Austritt ist arbeiten so viele diverse mögen auf der auf der Pro brexit Seite.
Und vor allem ich meine muss man sich ja auch mal Klammer ich habe ja selber auch mit abgestimmt ich war in der glücklichen Situation weil ich ja vorher noch ein halbes Jahr da gelebt hat man
wann verliert er seinen Wahlrecht wenn.
Muffins ohne Ei.
So zu viel Jahre nicht mehr dort lebt aber ich war halt in der Situation ich habe diesen Zettel gesehen und alles was da drauf stand war möchtest du das UK aus der EU raus rückt ja oder nein das ist.
Aber nicht genau nach welchem Arten Weise.
Genau also was bedeutet das jetzt konkret ja oder was.
Wie musst du diese kein Rolle der konservativen Partei,
und diese kleinen Rolle seit 2016 von Theresa May zurück also die diese beiden Dingen führen uns,
so den jetzigen Situation erstens warum ist diese Referendum über haupt hast du Stammel.
David kammenos der Parteivorsitzender der Tod geworden ist,
der hat mit diesen Sojus skeptische Flügel der konservative Partei sind gespielt da ghezaal 2006 wenn ich Parteivorsitzender gewinnen wenn ich diese Wahl Gewinne.
Nehme ich die britischen Tories aus der Europäischen Volkspartei mit dem Europäischen Parlament und wir bilden uns eine Fraktion
also keine alliierte mit politischen Parteien mehr und das hat er dann 2009 getan also da hat er schon an Unterstützung unter die Zoe oevo skeptisch oder Flügel der Partei dann gewonnen.
Dann 20620 seine sorry musste dann diese Koalitionsregierung zusammen mit den Liberalen dann binden bilden
und die Lippe an und dann waren dann pro europäisch und dann die Parteimitglieder der Kommissar mit ihm waren dann super sauer und dann um dann die Partei zu beruhigen,
warte dann sich für ein Volksabstimmung geäußert parteiinternen 20.13 obwohl nie,
die Absicht hatte so ein Volksabstimmung überhaupt ohne sieren Simonsen wann 20/17 dann lade 13 Ladie die Konservativen deutlich hinter labour in den Meinungsumfragen.
Okay gut ich kann das nicht in die IT system Volksabstimmungen danach meine Partei besprechen.
Ich muss dich nie machen also kein gefahren.
Danach schaue ich über sie dann gewann dann kamen bis Unterhauswahl 20:15 Uhr und ich musste dann etwas machen was sie nie machen wollte.
Dann dazu auch dann weil man nicht so an also kurzfristig denkende.
Dicker ja der hat nie einen Strategie als Politiker das so gedacht okay,
wir brauchen keinen brexit Plan war brexit wird sowieso nicht passieren weil in den Meinungsumfragen am M beginnen da da da der Referendum
stand es bei 60 zu 40 für den Verbleib,
also heute Alter hat dann einfach so okay ja wir machen das möglich schnell also kein Gefahr ich setze mich selbst im Mittelpunkt also ich habe euch ich habe Focus mein Wahl gewonnen kein Problem.
Also es war dann wegen dieser Partei interne Spannungen der konservativen Partei das SEPA Psycho zustande gekommen ist und diese schlechte Rolle gespielt von von von David Hameln bis Vorwissen references.
Wieso Periode nach den einfach rein und dann spielt dann Theresa May eine sehr sehr wichtige Rolle aber diese dieses brexit was was auf den Tisch jetzt gerade liegt die sind diese austrittsabkommen,
und das bringen Großbritannien so eine Richtung von einer harten brexit course also raus aus dem Binnenmarkt und raus aus der Zollunion,
das ist alles wegen Krise meierwiese Mabel auf jeden Fall Einwanderung in Großbritannien begrenzen außer die sie will unbedingt eine ende der Personenfreizügigkeit.
Und da war sie ja schon immer eine Hardliner rin.
Genau sie wach hahaha gegen Einwanderung Asia zwischen 2010 und 2015 Innenministerin war
sie wollte unbedingt Einwanderung begrenzt also das war jetzt seit Jahren höchste Priorität wird Renesmee
Continental obwohl sie offiziell für den Verbleib war.
Ja dann brexit aswege von letztendlich können wir dann ein Warnung begrenzen,
okay das leitete danzwiesen may dann so einen harten brexit Kurs um Einwanderung zu begrenzen und dann,
anderen brexit wären wann möglich
aber das ist dann den Bund wo wir dann um in dieser Situation gelandet gelandet sind genau wegen diesem Ace eigene Linie we want to take back control auf alles Armani anobo.de,
wiederholt sich immer wieder und das ist dann die brexit Linie der Regierung geworden Einwanderung muss begrenzt werden,
und das ist dann höchstes Priorität in der brexit Behandlung für Großbritannien dann geworden.
Das Lästern die Konservativen in eine sehr komplizierte Lage weil eigentlich die kommt ja mit ihm waren immer die Partei für für Großunternehmen,
Großunternehmen brauchen Arbeitskräfte und Arbeitskräfte,
zu kriegen ohne Personenfreizügigkeit vertan in der Zug und dann schwieriger also dann stoßen dann die Interessen der Großunternehmer gegen die Interessen der konservativen Partei sehen wir dann mal wie das dann dann dann mit und für sich dann ausgeht.
Und es sind ja nicht nur die großen Firmen in den großen Städten seines ist ja auch im Prinzip genau dieser Gürtel der für den brexit gestimmt hat wo die Tory Unterstützer sind im Norden Englands oder im Umland was haben wir's nicht von Landwirtschaft geprägt ist und auch die Landwirtschaft ist ja auf den
Zustrom von.
Die schießen sich morgen mitnehmen.
Leuten angewiesene.
Und und auf dieser war gar Wirtschaft also.
In der Garage achtzig Prozent der Leute haben für den Austritt gestimmt und danach so im moment mal dann kriegen wir keine EU Subvention mehr ja und warum haben die das nicht verstanden vor dem bravo dem Volksabstimmung ja ja.
Und wir kriegen keine Arbeit dafür.
Na ja ja ja ja ja ja genau.
Was ist eine dramatische Situation und jetzt.
Habe ich gerade so viele tiefe Missverständnisse
wo dieses Volksabstimmung Wald wie du vergessen gesagt hast auf dem Zettel stand wir verlassen die EU,
habe viele weiße Befürworter haben sie niemand hat die haben sich den bitte mal anzufassen ja bevor du fleißig ich habe ganzen also das geht ja nicht weiß alte
aber wenn man schaut jetzt solltest du die sind diese diese Kampagne die haben alle Vorteile merchandise super vorgestellt ohne je alle Bild Schlagzeilen,
Camille stimmen aber das ist wie die die die vorangegangen sind.
Ja und jetzt sind wir in so einer Phase angekommen sieht man darf ich nur als Dreadlock bezeichnen kann also nichts geht mehr es gibt für nichts eine Mehrheit,
es gibt auch keinerlei klare Führungsperson
ja der mit der EU ausgehandelte austrittsvertrag,
und wohlgemerkt es handelt sich dabei erstmal nur um einen austrittsvertrag mit einem kleinen amendment wo drin steht wie man sich das so in etwa in der Zukunft mal vorstellen könnte wie es denn da läuft,
weil die muss ich ja auch an der Stelle komplett durchgesetzt hat wie die Verhandlungen zu laufen habe
sie hat einfach gesagt wir machen jetzt erstmal das und dann sagt er uns erstmal zu wie viel Geld werden noch von euch bekommen weil ihr habt ja hier langfristige zu sagen
gemachtes habe ich auch schon in der ganzen Debatte über so ein Missverständnis so nach dem Motto rupert jetzt müssen wir auch noch Geld bezahlen nur umzugehen wir kommen denn da zu hier geht's ja nicht um einen.
Ausgleich für irgendeinen Verlust sondern hier geht der um die konkreten Zusagen zudem sicher Großbritannien also die Pläne die Finanzpläne der EU gehen ja auch,
10 Jahre teilweise noch weiter mit rein und am Ende,
müssen sich die britische Regierung ja diesen Zeitplan im Verhandlungssaal Plan unterwerfen an dessen Ende dann wiederum einen Angebote EU stand.
Was ja dann wiederum ihren ursprünglichen ansagen,
auch nicht entsprach was dann wiederum zu Explosion der iraci Hase der ganzen Hardcore brexiteers Boris Johnson und andere wahnsinnige geführt hat die ja dann alle aus der Regierung gegangen sind.
Bitte aber aber es gibt so viele diverse Meinungen innerhalb von den beiden großen Parteien in Großbritannien also man hat grob das,
kurz zusammenzufassen es Gewinner von den Konservativen etwa 50 brexit HBO radikalen Menschen diese sogenannten European research Kuh die wollen
unbedingt raus möglich schnell und so jeden Preis also raus ohne Einigung der Bus,
dann hat man einen großen Teil von den Konservativen die Eltern für einen Austritt sind aber einen Austritt mit einem Abkommen.
Habe die können diese Linie von Theresa May oder weniger unterstützen,
ja es ist für manche davon vielleicht ein bisschen zu hart oder bisschen zu hart gegen Einwanderung aber grob.
Kubuntu Sturz von den Parteimitglieder es gibt dann 20.
Etwa 20 konservativen wie sehen den wirtschaftlichen Schaden von sowas und die wollen doch noch bleiben also das ist so den Stand innerhalb der konservativen.
Dann innerhalb der Labour Partei ist es so 55% Prozent gesehen ja so etwa 120 Abgeordnete cemedi jeweilige Gruppe.
120 Jahre leben an Gordon Bohlen auf auf jeden Fall bleiben und sie bereiten ein zweites Volksabstimmung so unterstützen damit Großmüttern bleiben,
alles geht dann noch etwa 120 Ohm corbyn Design ok wer wir respektieren dieses Volksabstimmungen wer wir wir sind bereit so rauszugehen
haben wir wollen einen sogenannten Jobs first brexit also das ist was pascorbin gerade er vorschlägt wir wissen nicht genau was das bedeutet ein Wort Überdosis bei Krebs ist grob vielleicht so eine etwas anfangen trägst du das was sie dann kommt die Konservativen Ball.
In der Realität,
Tipps nicht so viel Unterschied zwischen die Positionen von dieses E-Mail-Listen und die Kopien Loyalisten aber das Problem ist die SIM,
Tory und labour das bedeutet die die wollen nie nie nie mehr da noch keinen Fall miteinander kooperieren das Bedeutung wo die Positionen sind genau gleich,
die finden keine keine Einigung,
Buddy die sind diese beiden diese beiden Gruppen das ist einen guten Film wir finden befinden sich jetzt in die in genau in die in dieser Lage so viele Bridge Abgeordneten sehen,
deren Rolle innerhalb von die jeweiligen Parteien als höchste Priorität und alles andere ist ist die zweithöchste.
Dann um so ein bisschen zu meine Schlussfolgerung Sissi und was wird dann passieren.
Wie heiß waschen höchstwahrscheinlich das Chance ist dann man findet dann ein Mehrheit,
für eine Verlängerung ja einfach kein brexit ohne ohne Einigung kein Unitymedia.
Keine einseitige Rückzug des Artikel 50 Brief ist also eine folge kann ich kann von alleine her,
entscheiden okay bestanden das ganze Ding also alle diese drei Optionen es gibt keine eine Mehrheit für diese drei es gibt vielleicht eine Mehrheit für wir brauchen mehr Zeit.
Es könnte dann passieren dass das britische Unterhaus stimmt am 27 Februar ab.
Dann Theresa May nach Brüssel verschicken um auf eine Verlängerung zu bitten.
Das 3.
Nee also Großbritannien hat bis jetzt kein Verlängerung angefragt aber weil es gab bis jetzt keine Mehrheit in den Brötchen und Haus für eine Verlängerung der der der der Verhandlung.
Fit für die Verlängerung ist das jetzt überhaupt weitere.
Kann ich nicht ich gehe immer wieder nach Brust oder er ständig ja aber die Uhr tickt jetzt ja und jetzt gerade jetzt dass ich den Bildschirm und aus dann um so viel drückt und dann wird dann höchstwahrscheinlich dann Entscheidung treffen okay wir brauchen mehr Zeit.
Die Frage ist dann Bieri AG die EU darauf und was für Kriterien setzt dann die EU,
um Großbritannien dann mir Zeit zu geben.
Mit der Zeit ist ja ganz interessant weil man hatte ja bisher den Eindruck dass es eher Theresa Messmethode ist,
Druck auf die EU und Druck auf die anderen Abgeordneten zu entwickeln
dadurch dass diese dieses Notdienst denario also das was er jetzt automatisch passieren würde wenn nichts getan wird dass das sozusagen als große nario greift um Unterstützung für ihren Plan zu bekommen und irgendwie habe ich den Eindruck dreht sich das jetzt komplett oben,
der Druck
greift mich eben wegen dieses deadlock weil andere Sachen höre brütet haben und jetzt wird es aber auch an die er zu einem Druckmittel der EU die bisher ja eigentlich auf eine bemerkenswerte Art und Weise
eine Einheit.
Dargestellt hat und unglaublich wie 27 Länder so gut Prinzip auch eine Meisterleistung der Europäischen Kommission insbesondere von Michelle bannier.
Kannst du gucken Spieler.
Der im übrigen ja auch diese der auch schon bei den Karfreitagsabkommen mit dabei war und die Situation wirklich sehr gut kennt und.
Jetzt ist es ja eigentlich so dass Großbritannien irgendwie.
Gar keine andere Wahl mehr hat weil ich weiß dass es wird viel diskutiert mit diesem Notdienst denario aber soweit ich mir das anschaue.
Selbst wenn man das jetzt wollen würde wäre ja.
Mal was haben wir heute haben heute den 22 Februar jetzt wo wir hier sprechen das heißt jetzt im Prinzip noch ein Monat,
wenn man das mal in sitzungs Tagen des Parlaments ausrechnet sind es vielleicht noch zwei Wochen,
und ist glaube ich müsste sowas in der Größenordnung von 500 Gesetzesvorhaben beschlossen werden um überhaupt die rechtliche Basis für dieses Notdienst in nahezu Schaf.
Bethanien.
Also es ist es ist es ist wird nicht stattfinden können und deswegen ist die Frage wer zuckt zuerst und ich glaube die EU-Kommission wird jetzt einfach cool bleiben.
Die EU die EU Seite kann auf jeden Fall cool bleiben bei ok no-deal wäre eine Katastrophe kurzfristig auch für einige EU-Länder.
Also.
Wieland Belgien ohne Marzipan also fertig haben sie eine Verbindung mit Großbritannien aber.
Dass diese so no deal Szenario kann nicht monatelang dauern,
Ball im Fall einen Odile dann dover-calais ist dann dicht weil wenn man wenn man Zollkontrollen einführen muss.
Es gibt zwei mögliche Probleme in der Zulieferung von Medikamente nach Großbritannien.
Ja genau ein Kuss mit Hanne produzieren nur 70% der eigene Lebensmittel und was wusste Tannin produziert ist nicht was die Briten essen also Großbritannien exportiert dann im engeren gleichen importiert eine Menge Schinken und dann Hühnerfleisch zum Beispiel,
nee also das Ding ist ist with amazing haha also die EU will kein Audio brexit also das können wir daraus Auslastung Mittel und rund um die Uhr tickt das Gewehr Druckmittel verwenden,
alles funktioniert nicht das soll also tourismail zu einer,
Pistole in Richtung im Fuß von der EU an so eine andere riesige besuche gegen seinen eigenen Kopf also,
aber aber nicht dass sie denkt dass es umgekehrt ist ja so dass die die die die Briten haben gar nicht bestanden das Modell ist deutlich schlimmer für die für Großbritannien das für die EU,
und dann wenn du dir passiert dann eigentlich große Canin musste und schönen Verhandlungstisch kommen genauso tauchte in den Tagen danach.
Ich interessiere mich auch für diese Frage bricht Panik irgendwann mal nach außen in Großbritannien also beim im Jahr 2000 gab es einen Streik von Lkw-Fahrer die Andy benzin zu Tankstellen geliefert haben.
Innerhalb von drei Tagen standen riesengroßen Schlangen von von von Autofahrer an alle Tankstellen in Großbritannien die Wolle tanken
wir haben kein Benzin
okay ja wenn ich so dass wir haben kein Brot oder oder oder kein Waschmittel oder oder keine Tomaten Ja-Stimmen alle in den Supermärkten dann in einem kaufen alles ein also ist eine andere Frage,
also das ohne ohne wenn die die Wettervorhersagen sagen dass dass das
das Schnee könnte kommen die wurden gestohlen den zu bemerken nur noch einkaufen die ganze Bank Bienen sein also vorher
Fotos Schnee kommt also wenn am 20. März no deal brexit droht also ich will ich wäre nicht erstaunt wenn alle gehen zu den nächsten Tesco Soda Saint Wiesen kaufen alles ein,
ja also also nur die dass du deine Auto angucken wo mich denkt dann eigentlich das no deal.
Die Nougat Jordan im britischen Unterhaus haben verstand dass nur die keine keine Lösung ist das kann nicht passieren.
Aber die können sich nicht darauf einigen was was für eine Alternative ist möglich okay.
Missing countries Männer Fussel um dann in einer Verlängerung von der EU anzufragen ok paßkamp Russland okay ja wir gehen euch dann vielleicht,
habe nur unter diese Kriterien und die Kriterien könnten dann sein okay.
Wann oder was für eine Lösung ist dann in Sicht und eine Lösung wäre dann vielleicht einen neuen Unterhauswahl,
oder dann an sogenannt people's vote dann ein Volksabstimmung zu den dann zu den austrittsabkommen und dazu die Verdi sind dann zwei.
Endgültigen Lösungen also wenn das britische Unterhaus blockiert ist dann schicken wir wieder die Frage ans voll.
Aber unter Auswahl würde doch auch nicht viel helfen.
Ja aber es gab es schon so viele Fehlentscheidungen durch dieses Prozess also es wäre aus meiner Sicht Blödsinn ein und Haus war so ungesehen aber,
ja das schon ich 20 sie denn getan können Sie das doch doch noch machen,
also die SGS gibt es gab in den letzten die letzten dieser letzte Woche mal wie die Gerüchte dass ein und Haus war dann passieren könnte wegen diesen diese Gründung dieses und an unabhängige Gruppe Arten von einem georden,
am das swissmade davon aus dass das hatte eine deutlich größere Einfluss auf labour aus auf die Tories dann mach mal jetzt plötzlich eine einen wieder einen eine unter Auswahl.
Enttäuscht können das dann gewinnen und dann die können dann die die die brexit Pläne von Medan implementiert ich denke das so Schwachsinn aber es könnte doch kommen leider.
Aber am Ende ist eigentlich die einzige Möglichkeit das ganze über das sogenannte people's vote Projekt durchzuführen.
Ich mag Referenten nicht was sie sagen aber ich sehe keine andere Lösung.
Also dass das über eine parlamentarische weg irgendwie rückgängig machen geht nicht alle möchte Messis gibt keine Wahl mehr ein für irgendeine brexit Variante mondhaus gerade also das.
Oh das bringt dann Großbritannien so ein LogiLink wie und das ist sehr sehr schädigend! Lieber also das liest du hast oder ne türkistan ein Piep Fußball.
Redet mal viel über den Schaden der noch so entstehen könnte aber der Schaden der schon entstanden ist der ist ja auch nicht gerade gering
letzten zwei drei Wochen hatte man Meldungen von zahlreichen Unternehmen die angekündigt haben dass er entweder Ihren Betrieb komplett einstellen wie z.b. flybe im Aldi eine sehr nationale,
Linie ja teilweise in Europa auch in Deutschland ein paar Verbindungen betrieben hat.
Honda und Nissan ja ja.
Der Automobilmarkt ist richtiges Problem weil es ja im Prinzip auch so fast noch zu die letzte große Industrie ist die Großbritannien überhaupt noch,
zu bieten hat Airbus habe ich schon immer als Knackpunkt gesehen insbesondere auch als Problem für die
EU weil das ist ja nun wirklich ein Unternehmen was extrem verflochten ist und eben darüber hinaus auch eine paneuropäische Bedeutung hatte
heißt nicht nur einer eine rein britisches Projektor etwas was nur Frankreich Deutschland und Großbritannien betreffen würde da hängt ja ne ganze Menge dran,
und ich sehe auch einen erheblichen Schaden und das auch schon,
seit dem Tag der Abstimmung insbesondere im wissenschaftlichen System und am Ende natürlich auch,
City.
Also das stimme ich vollkommen zu und auch wenn Großbritannien bleibt,
da wird sie Jahren brauchen um den Ruf Großbritanniens wirtschaftlich sowie weltpolitisch Odins Maßnahmen politisch wieder aufzubauen,
also das hat schon so vielen Brücken zerstört an.
Das Großbritannien kam rüber aus nicht so vertrauenswürdiges Land ja ich das stimme ich vollkommen zu natürlich die schlechtesten Folgen des brexit wirtschaftlich kann man doch noch stoppen,
oder nimmerfall unbrexit mehr so einen sanften brexit unbrexit mit ein Abkommen dann vielleicht die gehst dann Großbritannien gar nicht so schlimm also ein Grund warum.
BMA oder oder Honda zurzeit genauso viele Ängste haben ist die dass diese no deal brexit droht also eine brexit mit einer Einigung wäre.
Weniger schädlich für Großbritannien wird schaffe ich schon von von dem Beruf her aber ja ich stimme dir vollkommen zu also Großbritannien ist gerade in einen Laden in einer in einer,
eine Suche tuta Zion's Krise.
Aber könnt ihr das nicht dann auch ein Vorteil sein langfristig weil wir haben ja festgestellt.
Ohne eine Reform dieses Wahlsystems kann sich das alles ja auch nicht so ohne weiteres gab's da nicht sogar schon mal eine Abstimmung vor ein paar Jahren.
Ab 2011 eine Abstimmung zu dem Thema aber das Problem das vorgeschlagene Lösung war so miserabel also so einer nicht deine durchgehende gute gute Lösung ist er hieß auch keine TÜV damals also
ich habe selbst für dieses Reform gestimmt aber es war keine tiefgehende gute Reform Ding ist.
Außer die schottische national isn niemand hat guten so konstitutionelle Reformvorschläge geradeaus und niemand kümmert sich,
drumherum meine mittelfristige der Hoffnung wäre dass man könntest auch den Dingen reformieren aber ich habe keine große Hoffnung dass man das finden in den nächsten paar Jahren hinkriegen könnte es wäre meine Hoffnung,
aber ich sehe dich ich halte die Chancen für Seegering.
Auch nach diesem ganzen Drama.
Aber die Bullen haben nicht verstanden dass wir haben eine Politik rede fahren also die die Dinge hier brexit also ist die Krisen nein die Krise geht tiefer also
alle Sims kannst du Brötchen politische System ist gerade kaputt die Parteien funktionieren ja nicht so richtig Vertrauen in den britischen Unterhaus ist ganz gering
Problem mit dem Haus Oberhauser lose Oberhaus ist nicht gewählt es gibt keine schriftlichen Verfassung Großbritannien ist das Finanzen finanzielles zentralisiertes Land der EU mit 97% der öffentlichen Finanzen in den Händen von den Finanzminister immer so die Regionen haben fast keine Macht auf der Schottland und ein bisschen.
Wirtschaftliches Großbritannien so genauso ist London im Südosten gegen den Rest die dringende drei Formen der das Sozialsystem und Gesundheitssystem,
Infos zu chorsprechen Regionen also
herausgaben in Norm,
aber ja also all das ist noch schwieriger oder unten schlimmer wenn Großbritannien tritt aus der EU dass du so lieber als höchstes bedeutet zuerst brexit stoppen
und dann man kann dann hoffen dann mal man könnte diese anderen Problem lösen aber laboured und die Konservativen haben keine Antworten auf die meisten von diese Frage,
und auch die haben sich nicht darum gekümmert die letzten Jahren,
also die haben verpasst keinerlei andere Gesetze aus dem brexit Gesetze abgestimmt in den letzten 6 Monaten weil die haben keine parlamentarischen Zeit dafür.
Pekip-gl es gibt Verzögerungen in die in dem Bau von diese neue Bahn Linie 1 Richtung Nordwesten
die haben nächsten die dass die überhaupt nicht debattiert in den Unterhaus in den letzten Monaten ja so ist es echt tot den aus für dieses Projekt W wegen die Verzögerungen also,
Bridge in the bridges politics steckt gerade in eine sehr sehr tiefe Krise aber die die die Briten haben das nicht so wirklich bestanden Aussicht wenn man stimmt wenn man wohnt in Deutschland geht versteh mich nicht falsch Deutschland ist kein politisches Paradies,
aber wenn man behindernd und sieht was noch funktioniert und dann Blick nach Großbritannien dann sieht man wie tief die Krise da in Großbritannien ist die Briten haben dieses Außenperspektive.
Was musst du denn passieren in der britischen Gesellschaft damit irgendwas also muss dann er muss erst alles explodieren.
Gute Frage so das habe ich mal machbar überlegen.
Emma denkt ja ja lieber ein Modell wann ist sie dann wie wie schlimm das dann gehen könnte aber dann denke ich meine meine meine Familie meine Freundin im Moment war also das ist ein Schritt zu weit
meine lieblings Lösung wäre also wenn ich dann ein bisschen so YouTube ist aber auch halbwegs realistisch dann denkt.
Eine brexit Verlängerung Volksabstimmung entweder im Herbst dieses Jahr oder Frühling nächstes Jahr Frühlingsanfang.
Großbritannien stimmt für den Verbleib.
Sprich Dank aus aus in Hamburg konservativen also die concept die bleiben nicht zusammen Schlitten in so einer AFD Missgeschick skeptisch Partei und so weiter bürgerliches CDU mascot Partei.
Dann ich muss dann ein Unterhauswahl geben und gewinne der Unterhauswahl wäre dann labour aber nicht mehr deine Mehrheiten und können dann nur
zusammen mit den schottische national wissendaner dann regieren
und die rufen dann ins Leben dann an so ein Verfassungskonvent um die Spannung zwischen Lohn und und Edelrose lösen
und die die schottischen Hudson wissen werfen dann anderen Themenfeldern ins in diesem Topf und Großbritannien macht dann 20-20-20 21 eine tiefgehende
Verfassungsreform also das wäre meine ob die mich nicht weniger hinaus hier ja,
mut ist nicht sauer sein aber da.
Na ja aber warum muss ich finde es klingt.
Straubing ProSieben.
Ja zumal weil Schottland könnte vielleicht wirklich so ein bisschen die Lösung sein weil
was ja auch schon anklingen lassen es gab ja schon mal auf diesen Wunsch sich ab zu spalten in der SMP ist der sehr stark und ich kenn Schottland so ein bisschen.
Schnell wenn man wenn man da ist wann er dann brauchen wir mit Schotten spricht auch auf dem Land man merkt halt sehr schnell ja okay alles klar England ist das hier nicht so ja also.
Und ich ganze politische Debatte und die Beteiligung ist ganz anders schau mal was für eine Art von Politiker sind sie sind bei den beiden smts gibt super junge Menschen super alte Menschen komische Menschen Krug
Menschenfrauen Professoren
ist möglich auch nicht unecht coole Menschen also im Vergleich zu den grauen Männer 6 Jahre alt sind in den den konservativen aussehenden Anzüge bei den bei den Tori ist es ist was ganz anders.
Schottland sozusagen so ein bisschen als sie als das Zukunftsmodell für.
Ja ja weiß ich irgendwie anderes,
und und und es war so lebendig ich fahre ich waren schon eine Woche lang vor den schottischen Volksabstimmung und und diese diesem Bürgerbewegungen
für einen unabhängigen Schottland sese interessant zu wissen,
also den die haben sowieso grassroots Politik richtig gehabt Sinn in den schauen wann hat das haben die noch also diese.
Dieser sympathisch Beteiligung was ist im großen Teil von Großbritannien zur total fehlt das existiert ja schon in Schottland so Politik ist insgesamt
lebendiger.
Ja John.
Dauer des Hammers war ganz gut zusammengefasst ich fand das jetzt eine sehr runde Geschichte super vielleicht kommen noch mal zusammen und.
Gerne ja ja.
Können ein paar Updates liefern aber ich glaube das eigentliche Ziel mal so die Gesamtsituation zu erklären dass er auf jeden Fall erreicht.
Gut also herzlichen Dank und ja wir haben was jetzt etwa 40 Tagen vor den Austritt Nachweis sogar bisschen weniger es wird interessant sein in denen gut danke.
Okay und ich sag auch danke fürs Zuhören das war die zweite Ausgabe von UKW ist wird hier bunt bleiben insofern danke fürs zuhören.